ryan was just quoting you
he was like oh dude he's from silicon
valley yes oh yeah and i go oh yes and
the first thing i say well what do you
know about silicon valley and what did
you say ryan oh it's this guy
there it is that's it and you know it's
funny i look at ryan because i walked in
here and i looked at you and no no no
disrespect but i think ryan's the guy in
the house doing all the
ryan is doing all the but what a
classic line do you have people come up
to you and say oh my god yes so much i
mean this guy is that right
this guy when i lived in new york
city
it's when i really realized oh my gosh
yeah that there that character and that
particular russian
russ hanneman resonated so much with
this sort of
18 to 55 year old
you know startup vc bro demographic and
it it's listen i i think it's i think
it's lovely when when you as an actor do
something that resonates with with the
fan base
it's it's gratifying it's challenging
when i'm walking my six-year-old
daughter and someone's like hey this guy
and she's like why do you say
daddy i'm like he said this guy's a fox
and she's like that's equally weird dad
equally weird really weird yeah but
that's cool though when people recognize
you and say oh my god it's a signature
yeah you know there's a signature line
it and and you know
look i have
i'm so
i'm so lucky i've i've only ever acted
in my life i've never held another job
since you were like nine right yeah i
did commercials and
and uh and your parents were all for
this so my folks and i do have to
give it to my parents man
because my parents are
lovely educated traditional greeks they
don't have a concept of you know sort of
like they're not stage parents they
didn't understand any of it what they
did fully recognize almost before i did
was that i had a keen desire to
entertain and and they knew
that they had to do something about that
what what was that were you were you
doing impressions like you were for me
just now yeah are you always what were
you doing yeah
i was doing i i when we would go to
greece in the summers we didn't have a
tv where
and and my parents would just have me
reenact uh stooge's shorts you know uh
and and it was it was just they saw that
it was more than just me messing around
they actually saw that there was skill
there